in candies but damn the Guardians.
arrived oh no that will set off the bomb.
immediately try again oh that's exactly.
where you just how's that even possible.
digital TV and theaters may fit
hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
is that a rifle you do know what a rifle
looks like it's just swords were your
thing and gun for mine but I guess we
both doing guns now I just didn't know
that that's intense
I see it within you fear jealousy
betrayal is it our duty to cleanse the
universe of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douche bags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong eye - seat belt on
so it's saving the galaxy again yeah! awesome
really gonna be able to jack up our
price it with two-time galaxy Davis
boys
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life
it's right there by your side along your
right
you are not science
No
of family
lucemon
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
you